Un contratista está comprando baldosas de piedra
para un patio de piedra nuevo,
cada baldosa cuesta 3 dólares
y quiere gastar menos de 1000 dólares,
y aquí está diciendo menos de
¿ok?
Y quiere decir que el gasto debe ser
menor que 1000,
no puede ser menor o igual.
El tamaño de cada baldosa es de 1 pie cuadrado,
así que
escribe una desigualdad que representa el número
de baldosas que puede comprar con un límite
de 1000 dólares,
y después descubre
¿Qué tan grande puede ser este patio de piedra?
Así que, sea
"x"
el número,
va a ser el número de baldosas compradas...
de baldosas
compradas
¿ok?
Entonces con "x" vamos a relacionar
el número de baldosas
que ha comprado este...
este contratista
y si queremos ver el costo total, pues simplemente
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 ¿verdad?
porque cada una de estas baldosas
cuesta 3 dólares,
y el costo total,
el costo total no debe pasar,
es decir, debe ser menor que
1000,
muy bien.
Entonces
para poder resolver esto,
lo que necesitamos es,
dividir ambos lados sobre 3 ¿verdad?
dividimos ambos lados sobre 3,
como ya vimos en el vídeo anterior
y realmente como estamos dividiendo
entre algo positivo,
puedes pensar que estamos
multiplicando por 1/3,
como es positivo en realidad no tengo que cambiar
el signo de la desigualdad, entonces,
esto se cancela
y tengo "x" menor que 1000 sobre 3 que son
333 y sobra 1/3
¿ok?
Entonces el número de baldosas
es menor que 333 1/3
baldosas
¿ok?
Ahora bien nos pregunta
¿Qué tan grande puede ser este patio de piedra? Entonces el tamaño,
el tamaño del patio...
tamaño del patio,
como...
como cada baldosa mide un pie cuadrado
pues no puede pasar de esta ¿verdad?
Que son 333 1/3,
aquí vamos a poner 10 cuadrados,
Muy bien.
Y hemos terminado.